hey everyone
uh it is gm josh fridell here
and uh presenting you with the
gm choice lecture so
once again it's going to be all right
let me mute myself
uh so i am reading the chat um so
if you want to do uh suggestions in the
chat and things like that i'll be asking
you questions the whole time
and stuff like that it was pretty crazy
at the club today but we are off and
running so
today i wanted to talk to you about a
very specific topic and i'm going to
present it in kind of a few different
ways
and i wanted to start
by showing you a piece of this game this
was between
dennis hizmatullin russian gm
and ralph mohammed of gm from
azerbaijan uh the opening was a king's
indian
with c5 and you'll notice how it's not
quite a benoni because the e and c pawns
haven't been traded
so it was kind of a weird looking king's
indian um
where black took on f3 g takes f3
and we're in this position where it's a
question of what white should do
to uh continue the attack which is
obviously raging on black's king
so there i should say that before i go
on that there are many many ways to do
this
but they're i'm looking for something in
particular so you're white and you have
to continue this attack what would you
do
yes davina actually the uh
the stream i did earlier uh for some
reason on one of the layouts the the
video was completely messed up and
i was unable to fix it but uh yes we're
back to a relatively normal webcam now
so
hopefully it won't be too painful
uh in any case uh so white to move and
again like i'm looking for a specific
type of idea here
e5 and the idea of
taking and f5 this is definitely
possible the one thing i would worry
about after something like this would be
takes f5 and even a move like g5 i know
this is kind of ugly
but the idea is that this actually kind
of stops you up and
positionally you're doing great you have
these these light square control you
have a really crappy
g7 bishop but when your goal is to
attack sometimes you're actually you're
closing things down so you're getting a
positional advantage but you're
sacrificing
some of your attacking potential so
that's kind of a potential drawback to
that
so i see a suggestion for king h1 rook
g1 and
that i think is a very good idea which
is what was played again it's not the
only way you could play with f5 for
instance
immediately without playing e5 first
because the bishop on the long diagonal
doesn't actually do that much
and the idea of f5 is you're trying to
just crack at these pawns maybe even
f4 and takes next maybe king h1 can
follow and if g5 now and you go back
it's not the same as if you've
sacrificed your e pawn it's
a lot more open ideas like f4 for
example or in the air
so f5 would also be a good move you have
any ways to do this but king h1
so this kind of starts my topic with
something really basic basically that
the king on g1 is just not ideal and you
want to fix it so this whole topic today
is and actually have to do with
the king more than anything else so i've
seen topics done like this where
like one of them of course the very
famous short game where he ran his king
all the way to h6 to give checkmate
which is really cool
but i would say that it's it's not as
common that kings just go
rampant like that unless it's the end
game
um so
but here it's more about like subtle
king moves
so again it looks like you have so many
ways to continue the attack but
after king h1 with the idea of rook g1
it's just like a little king move to
help bring pieces into the attack
because the rook on f1 is one of those
pieces where
on e1 it doesn't really do much there
are too many pieces in the way
if f5 f4 maybe it does something but the
rook doesn't really do anything on any
other square
so just the simple act of moving the
king out of the way all of a sudden
makes black's life extremely challenging
so black play tried the move queen b4
and the players repeated once they
played rook b1
rook back to g1 and then queen b4 so
repeating is one of those
things in chess where you'll see gm's do
it all the time and it doesn't mean
they're trying to draw it doesn't mean
they're trying
um to just see what their opponent's up
to all the time sometimes you just
repeat to gain time in the clock
sometimes you see if your opponent's
going to deviate or play a worse move
but you'll see it all the time and it
does not mean that they have any
intention of drawing of course black
would be okay with a draw here
um because their position is
kind of sketchy but white would almost
certainly not be okay with the draw
so the question now is how do you
continue the attack and how do you deal
with this queen takes b2 idea
so looking for some suggestions
so your idea is to play f5 and
completely ignore
this is not altogether stupid right
because you're
you're just continuing attack and you're
claiming that this pawn is not so
meaningful
the problem with taking here is that now
you have a rook oops sorry
forgetting i'm not on lead chess or
chess.com
um you're attacking the rook and the
queen so your queen would have to move
somewhere like this
and even here like you just don't want
to trade queens right so you couldn't
trade queens
and play like this and this is perfectly
okay but even here something like bishop
f6 might be annoying
with the idea that after takes takes all
of a sudden this rook is open
yes i still like your position after
something like rook takes b7 it still
looks terrible for black
but i feel like you're not checkmating
here and the games become a little
unclear
i would also say that like if you have
to play a move like queen d3 it's just
very awkward
um so i would say that again you want to
look for kind of different ideas here
so i see the suggestion of rook b3 i
think that's a good move
that's what was played um
but yeah i mean you have plenty of
different options here you could even
play something more aggressive but rook
b3 i think is just kind of nice
um
and the idea is simply that you're not
going to let them take on b2 you're
going to force them to take on a4
and now you're
claiming that the queen on b2 on a4 is
less annoying than the queen on b2
um but there was something very
interesting that he's matulin
saw here and once again it has to do
with the significance of the king so
i mean i'm kind of showing you some
games so not every single move has to do
with one of the
one of the kings but i would say that
the king is kind of the focus of today's
lecture so whenever you're not sure on
um what exactly to do it probably has to
do with one of the kings either
taking advantage of the placement of one
or improving the placement of another in
a significant way
so white has a really really nice
continuation here which has very much to
do
with taking advantage of the king
so while you guys are thinking uh just
to give you kind of an idea
uh one of the ideas i had for this
lecture because i kind of was
like a lot of my lectures i have
prepared i've given some of them before
um a lot of lectures are a little bit
more off the cuff this is kind of one of
them
so you always kind of hope it goes well
but one of the ideas is that
the the importance of the king i think
is something that's underestimated by a
lot of club players in particular
uh that they don't think about their
king and their opponents king too much
because usually all the other pieces
kind of get the action but i would say
in the end game of course the king is
very significant
and the king plays a very important role
in lots of positions both in terms of
whether it's weak or whether you improve
it or whether it's strong
so just thinking more about your king
more about your opponent's king
can i think really improve the play of
most people and a lot of the times when
i'm stuck in a position
and i'm not sure what to do i find that
oh i can improve my king and
so often it's just such a useful thing
to do
so so i'm seeing lots of one move
suggestions
which as you know i'm not as big a fan
of as i am of lines
um but
what else have you got here actually i'm
not going to show title games like one
of the things like i mean i
he was one of my favorite players
growing up and but i i try to
when i sh when i focus on players
actually two of the games i'm going to
show today in this lecture are from
gizmotulum
i i try to show games from players that
people might not know as well
uh because players like like almost
everyone's have seen their games
um obviously carlson kasparov like these
are
they're just more common so a lot of the
times i i'll show games of carlson i'll
show games of all these people but i do
like to
um showcase games of people who are
lesser known so i'm seeing a lot of
knight f5s i'm happy with knight f5 but
what exactly is your idea
what is the what is the key idea
so keep in mind guys that after knight
g3 you cannot move your b-rook
this is something that's very important
because your queen was going to hang
so harley is the best attacker he was up
there i mean
guys like kasparov i would not
underestimate in terms of attacking
there are plenty of other good attacking
players but you know target's games are
always really fun
for sure
so the main thing i'm looking for from
you guys is after knight f5 which is
definitely a move that you want to play
what is the idea if i play g takes f5
that is the main thing i'd like to see
from you guys and i see it
your idea is that you can play so netify
was played in the game
if g takes f5 you have the move rook
takes g7 check which is very strong
you'll probably have other ways to try
to go about the win but this is very
nice with the idea that after king takes
you have check
and you're actually using the pin
against black because now they have this
queen that's loose
so again a fairly simple idea but you
want to make sure you see it before you
just throw a knight into f5 right
so the move b5 maybe was the best
defense here something like this
but after something you can even just
take this bishop off the board
play check and then f5 and as you can
see black's king is in
huge trouble so i don't think black
would have lasted very long
instead black tried to move e5
and again there are quite a few ways to
try to finish this off
white took on e5 with the pawn and black
took it to rook
so how did his matulin finish the game
and again take your time and i want a
complete line again it should not just
be one move
so something which i've been saying
every day now because i've been teaching
uh kids classes and stuff like that and
all the time i'll see suggestions in the
chat of just one move
and almost never ever am i looking for
one move i'm almost always looking for a
move with an idea a very specific
variation
so it's just something i i tell people a
lot
so you can see one move but one move
doesn't tell me anything you know
one move maybe you saw really far ahead
maybe you saw one move ahead and
it's very rare in chess you don't want
to look ahead and see what's going to
try to ha what's going to happen
um but the reason i mentioned his
maturing is because i think he's a very
interesting player to watch
like he was in 2015 i think he actually
hit like 27
20 or 30. so he was a very legitimate
player still is
now he's in the lower 2600s but he's one
of those players where almost
all his games like so many of his games
are crazy and interesting
and he takes lots of risk and he's just
kind of a fun player to follow but he's
not one of the very top he's not a
carlson he's not a carawan he's not a
ding he's not
a nakamura right so it's like people
aren't gonna follow his games they're
not gonna think to look at his games
but the fact is that he's still a very
strong player and for most people
the difference between him and carlson
like you can still get so much out of
his games
right but i just find that they're
really really interesting and he plays
the kind of chess which at the top level
isn't as common guys like dubo maybe are
the closest but
um so he's kind of a player that i found
really interesting to follow
so um but it's one of those things where
i like to show games by players who are
a little bit lesser known
so i'm seeing some ideas um
so tarun your idea of knight takes d6
and knight takes f7
it's not bad but i would say like knight
takes f7 like i'm not obligated to take
your knight right and i might be able to
defend against the threat of knight
takes f7
um now i don't think knight takes d6 and
that is a poor move by any means like
this is again a position where you
probably have many ways to win
but in general i'm looking for something
that's nice and clean and doesn't allow
any kind of play and finishes the
opponent
off really quickly uh the player i'm
talking about dino is is dennis uh
he's matulin a russian player
but again it's just the the point is
more that there are so many players who
are kind of under the radar but are
still really interesting to follow so i
like to follow
to show some of their games the the game
i'm gonna show
um the final one of his is actually one
of the most
uh one of the coolest tactical ideas i
i've seen like one of the coolest mating
ideas i have seen
that he came up with so we'll see that
at the end
so i'm seeing lots of ideas here uh but
once again i'm seeing like one move
things right that does not tell me
anything
um
so yeah you're suggesting f4 rookie 8
knight takes d6 knight takes d6 knight
txd6 looks very solid to me that should
be good enough
um but just to give you an example
knight takes d6 maybe the queen comes
back
now i'm fitting the knight you could
take on b7 i guess and then rook c8 but
the game's not over yet to give you an
idea the game end in like two moves
so the game did not last for another
five ten fifteen moves the game ended in
two moves pretty much
three moves uh he's mature and i'll give
you guys the spelling here
so again just kind of an interesting
player to follow so you can play f4
first
uh but the problem with f4 may be that i
can take on e4 now
and the idea is again i'm using your
pinned rook against you so uh
if you take i can take here if you don't
i might take on e2
so i'm not oops i'm not saying that
f4 is necessarily bad but allowing rook
takes e4 maybe is not the best idea
but also guys think how do you decimate
the king like how do you make it so that
it's really forcing so knight takes d4
is just
knight t's d6 is a super nice move i'm
not gonna say that's a poor decision
but again the game ended in three moves
how did he finish him off much faster i
don't actually see the solution just yet
so i'm seeing ideas like bishop g3 again
all probably okay
um you have a position that's so good
that you have many ideas but keep in
mind rook takes e4 is a resource if you
just attack the rook
so i'd much prefer something a little
bit more forcing
so i'm seeing knight takes g7 king takes
g7 queen c3 pinning the rook that's
very strong potentially i guess i can
move the king though and then unpin
myself
so i'm not 100 positive it's that clear
so you want to look not a you want to
look at your tempo moves you want to
look at your
um you know most the biggest threats you
can make in a position
that's one of the keys to being able to
uh kill this attack and also look at
what your opponent's key defenders are
so that should help you out basically
you want to eliminate a key defender you
want to look for your tactics for your
tactical ideas
and that's going to be how you finish
off someone in a situation like this
so aryan you're close with knight takes
g7 qt h7 queen c3 king g8 bishop f6 but
you have a much better version of this
so again guys look for your more um look
for your checks
look for your captures look for things
like that always try to get
more forcing knight takes h6 bishop h6 i
don't know that you're achieving too
much
and once again guys it is a line so if
you're giving one move you're probably
not correct
yeah that's the one direction no matter
how many times i give it
it doesn't work so you do start with
knight takes g7
the king pretty much has to take
otherwise it is a free piece
uh and now
no queen c3 bishop f6 ah
this is a very nice move and again it's
due to the fact that you have
this the potential for discovery
so the king cannot actually take this
bishop
play rook f3 check very nice there's a
really cool idea actually and i didn't
spot this when i prepared the lecture i
just spotted it while i was waiting
after king here uh
what are your options in this position
of course you can take the rook and be
winning but you have a better move
so rook takes b7 which is really kind of
a cool idea
again probably not the only way to win
so probably the queen has to go back to
e8 but then you could take the rook or
even not take the rook honestly like the
bishop on f6 is so good
i'd be tempted to just continue
attacking but you're up material with an
attack but the idea is it takes the
queen
check and now you have a lovely windmill
now you could be
brutal about it you could take on a7 but
okay obviously this
is just going to be made the simplest
method is just like this
and then either rook g7 or rook h8
something like this
so just kind of a cool idea i didn't
actually spot that when i was preparing
this game but rook takes b7 is a very
cool idea
and you actually give checkmate with
that windmill so very nice
um so in the game king g8 was played and
now
what move made black resign
yeah queen d2
so the nice thing about the move queen
d2
is that you're hitting the h6 pawn so
taking this rook is impossible
because that that mate will not be
stopped and there's just no good way to
stop it if i move like king h7 you can
play rook takes b7 you can take the rook
at any time
um after a move like knight d7
i'm pretty sure you can actually just go
go about your business by taking on h6
if you wanted
and then to play here uh i guess knight
h5 bishop h5 you still live for a couple
moves but
you're not going to live for any
extended period of time
so in the game he just resigned after
queen d2 but really kind of a brutal
demolition
uh just a really really nice game and
again this was a very basic example but
notice how both kings played such an
important role king h1 was really
important to allow the rook to g1
because it allowed knight f5 tactics to
begin with
uh f5 looked nice but putting the knight
on f5 and eliminating the bishop was
just
killing and then notice all the tactics
based on black's king due to the queens
right
so taking advantage of black's king
position and improving your own king
position and
in order to make your look nice so again
this is a very small example of
improving the king the next two will be
a little bit more
um a little bit like
more extreme not extreme but like it'll
be less subtle let's put it that way
okay so let us move on
alright so you get to see fish for a
couple seconds
and now because these games never end up
in order it's one of those things
all right and here we go
enjoy the fish forget the type of fish i
i used to know all the types of fish i
forget but uh anyway nice fish
hope you like them so this position is
white to move this was actually i hate
to tell you from a game of mine it was
actually played in st
louis in 2007 uh 2017 sorry
2017 at the fall classic
a round robin event that's held there
quite often
and i had a very very successful
tournament there i was able to win it
um and this was kind of the game that
decided it so it was a very important
game for me as far as like trying to
clinch the tournament
um
and this kind of was a really big moment
in the game so
i thought that like my opponent
definitely thought that their position
was quite good throughout the game
and i was under the impression i was
better for most of it i would say that
at some points they were okay and that
at other points i was better but it was
one of those where
we really disagreed on what the position
was about just based on how we talked
about it afterwards a little bit
uh which is very common like people have
different ideas and positions and
but i would say that the main
disagreement was that i had
different ideas about kings and the
king's safety
and the significance of that
so this position is white to move
and what would you guys do and you
probably have more than one good move
again
when it's from a game it's very rare
like okay this is the only continuation
it happens
um but i think that uh what occurred in
the game i actually found
um what i thought was quite decent
there's actually a little bit better
which i'll have you guys find as well
um but the question is how to proceed
here
so first of all like can anyone tell me
what's going on because i think like
summarizing the position is extremely
important here
now
so i'm not seeing any summaries i'm
seeing move suggestions which i'll get
to later but i'm looking for a summary
right now like what is going on here
what is important
look to switch to the king side
yeah i mean you guys are really focused
on this knight g5 idea which i think is
really good
because that's one of the major things
one of the major factors
um that i was looking for in this
position so white definitely has more
space that's significant
but i would say that normally by most
slav standards
blacks traded off a lot of the queen
side so
you know things are liquidated heavily
so if everything trades
at least in theory the d4 pawn should be
weak
but the fact is that i think black's
king especially against knight g5 ideas
is just quite weak because there's no
real way to fix it on the back rank
so of course if i get a knight to g5 and
queen to h3 it would be
really good but that's kind of not
feasible but just the idea of knight g5
and playing against the back rank
is actually quite strong
but the question is still how do we
proceed in this particular position
uh keep in mind we have pretty good
pressure on the queen side as well we
don't necessarily like i saw a
suggestion somewhere for this which
first of all
uh i mean after this at the very least
they could even think about trading
queens which
i don't know i don't want to say it
alleviates all the pressure but it
definitely
and first of all they don't have to take
they could try to go here and go after
the b-pawn or something
um but even if they go for this this
position right
king takes now maybe they try to improve
their king play rook b8 to try to attack
the b-pawn
it's not entirely clear to me that we're
the ones who are doing that amazing here
i mean yes our position probably is
decent but
i don't know how clear it is let me put
it that way so i don't know about all
these trading operations especially when
we're the ones who have
pressure
chileno and bogota yeah my mom knows
don't worry about it
she gave up long long time ago
to be fair though honestly i just have
too much stuff like
too much stuff but that's the way it
goes
okay
so i'm seeing suggestions for h4 i'm
seeing g4 but
again i'm not just looking for a move
i'm looking for a very clear idea
yeah it's a good
it's a good summary i like that summer
so h4 prevents rook b4 due to tactics i
would say that's probably true
but i don't think black's obligated to
play rook before either moves like rook
b6 for example i think are possible
um so you don't want to necessarily
assume that they have to do that right
ah but your idea of h4 is that you're
you're trying to prevent uh you're
trying to threaten rook takes a seven
due to check and knight g5 check ideas
yeah i definitely looked at h4 type
moves um
but i believe there was a way to defend
against it i'm trying to recall
uh so h4
so there's no threat immediately or is
there yeah there is okay
let me see
yeah i think h4 is actually perfectly
good as well
um
yeah i'm trying to think if i was
worried about this so
here and if rook takes a7 rook takes a4
uh rook takes here and then
i don't know this looks pretty good some
kind of
check yeah i think i looked at this
this is what i looked at i remember now
something like this and the idea is that
if here
there's a check and then they take our
rook which is kind of annoying i still
thought this was good for white but
um i ended up choosing something else
but as mentioned like
these uh
yeah you could bring your queen back but
again you you can do something more
forcing uh
as well um
but okay i mean there are there are many
ways to go about this but the first
thing i saw and i saw this mentioned a
bunch is that this not an f5 is always
kind of annoying
so i decided to play g4 to face to uh
shoot the knight back
um so a lot of you mentioned knight g5
is an idea and this is a very strong
idea so
you're trying to do all this back rank
stuff and you also have this idea of
rook f3 i think i missed this idea
in the game and the f7 pawn is extremely
weak
so this knight g5 move would be really
really tough to answer i don't really
have a great suggestion for black here
honestly
um but
i came up with a slightly different idea
and i don't think it's as accurate as
knight g5
but i think it does it is very very
strong and puts black under lots of
pressure
uh and this is not an idea i saw
suggested in the chat so i'll give you
guys a few minutes
so rook c7 again is possible trading the
rooks but i don't know if trade in the
rooks necessarily serves a great purpose
for me i like my rook on c3
so i'm not so certain i want to actually
trade those
i have not played in qatar uh a couple
people i know
we're going to but i have not played
there
so i do see a suggestion and one of them
and it has to do with kind of the
topic and it was one of the reasons why
i thought of this game because
the black king of course has great
significance in this game the if the
black king were not weak here probably
black would have a great position
because d4 is weak etc
but one of the issues is that i was
always getting checked on the back rank
in a lot of these lines
uh queen b1 check queen e4 so i didn't
think there was a huge rush
so i simply improved my king here
and again i i think knight g5 was better
but after king g2 my opponent went into
a very very deep think here
and one of the things i noticed was that
they became increasingly uncomfortable
they were kind of okay with their
position before this
but after the move king ji too which is
a very simple king move
i think that they were very very unhappy
and the reason for this is because after
king g2 and then
the next move king g3 black simply has
no great moves
and the problem that they have is that
eventually i'm just going to
improve my pieces further maybe try to
play knight g5 at some point
and even in the end game their position
is just going to be very lousy and it's
because i simply just improved my pieces
is it a grand mastery move i don't know
i mean i would say though that one of
the things you'll find when you look at
gm games there are often times when gm's
take
time out to say improve their king
or tidy up their position a little bit
whereas a lot of other players don't do
that and then
it's like by magic all of a sudden say
if a gm's playing a player who's
not as not as good or whatever again a
lot of the times it's not like they're
always great moves or that 2300s aren't
capable of playing these moves but
gm's are known for it where it's like
well we like to play little tidying
moves so we tidy up our position a
little so then when a mess breaks out
our position just looks nicer we have
pieces on slightly better squares and
all of a sudden it's like tactics seem
to work
and it's like the reason why they work
is because we've improved our pieces
housekeeping moves is something i've
said is something
my old coach um in new hampshire when i
first started out
used to say housekeeping moves and
they're the kind of moves that i find
are really useful because they just make
your position easier to play even if
they're not the most accurate moves all
the time
uh the way you have to do it is you do
it this way you ask yourself
if your opponent could do something
extremely strong or if you could do
something extremely strong but
oftentimes in positions
it's hard for both sides to improve and
then housekeeping moves just come into
play because they just make your
position a little
easier um
so that's kind of the idea so yeah i
mean h4 is again a move
um it's it's kind of hard to say because
like honestly there are a lot of good
moves here right like it's not like
there's just one good move
uh and i want to make that clear like if
you guys are like oh i wanted to play g4
or h4 i want to do it differently
it doesn't mean your way is bad right
your way could be just as good maybe
better than mine
uh it's more like i'm just showing you
kind of the way i think about the
position which is that again black's
very tied up
so i want to improve my pieces before i
start attacking them
so my opponent actually played g5 here
which is a little bit of a panicky move
but at the same time it's very
understandable because they want to get
out
of these back rank mate threats
they want to make sure that their knight
can have the g6 square they want to make
sure their king can get out
so g5 is actually not objectively
probably the best although it was
already a difficult position
but it's more the result of you panic
because you realize oh
i'm tied up my opponent is just making
these housekeeping moves these improving
king moves
i have to fix my king i have to do
something drastic so you'll see this
happen a lot actually
at least in my experience like i'll play
kind of a nice little improving move
and my opponent will be like ah and they
freak out and it's
it happens all the time because people
panic when they realize oh i don't have
easy moves
so the question is what to do here
so you're asking what g5 does again it
gives the king for some squares and it
gives the knight some squares
so taking on g5 is definitely a move uh
i was worried about some lines with
knight g6 i believe
um
and there were some other variations too
uh
there was another one for example after
here rook b4 there were some
complications as well
um i don't want to get into it too much
but basically the idea is that
after rook before uh
if i try this the idea is rook takes
queen e8 is mate so you have to take
either with the queen or take the queen
but after this i thought that there was
this and then rook g4 is a problem
um something like this was what i was
looking at and at the very least it
looked messy like maybe even here
there's knight f3
and then king h3 so i it's been a while
since i played this game i don't
remember all the details maybe rook b4
was not the move i was worried about
but i think like my logic was not so
much whether i could take the pawn like
it definitely was
but to me taking the palm is a loose
move if i take the pawn d4 is loose i
have to worry about rook v4 takes d4
there was some line actually that
irritated me it wasn't just general
concepts but
um i also thought do i have to take this
thing right away
is it moving anywhere because if f6
taking on e6 was possible and i can tell
you right away that if your opponent
plays a move like g5
they have in mind what to do against
knight takes g5
but you play an improving king move king
g3
and all of a sudden black still has the
same problem i don't have moves what do
i do
and the specific purpose of king g3 is
that now on knight g6 there are not even
any checks
you don't even have net f4 as a check so
it just makes your life that much more
annoying
uh this game was played in 2017.
so that was kind of my idea king g3
um that the g pawn's not going anywhere
and i'm slowly improving however there
was you can't just do it without
calculating at all i don't mean to imply
that
i'm just making improving moves and not
thinking of course there's some
calculation involved and
it kind of shows after this move
so rook b4 what do i play as white
and again i'm looking for kind of
complete variations once again
if f6 then the e6 pawn hangs that's
usually black's problem
so if at f6 i can always play rook takes
a6
so once again looking for full lines
so again this this rook c7 idea i keep
seeing it but it just trades rooks i
don't think you're actually achieving
that much
um and for example then you actually
have to be careful like rook c7 i want
to say be careful but
after something like this i could
consider a move like queen c1 with the
idea that now if you try to take my
knight
i can play queen f4 check and take here
and then take your knight
um so you have to be a little bit
careful about those ideas but it's more
just i don't know why you want to trade
those rooks um
queen a5 i'm seeing as a suggestion it
definitely makes some sense
uh queen a5 maybe a move like
queen b5 i'm not sure
i think maybe maybe just rook brook back
to b5 or something
i'm not sure
yeah rook back to b5 and if queen c7 the
rook hangs i don't know
definitely something to consider though
i've seen the right move
uh i've seen the right move but i have
not seen that variation accompanied so
so ah very very nice
um so very good job devina rook takes a7
is correct and i saw the suggestions of
this but i didn't see complete lines
so very simply if takes queen takes here
if takes on here which is what happened
in the game then i take back
and if rook takes it's very important
that queen eight check
leads to mate because here knight takes
check so the main idea is that
if king g6 then takes in mate if king h6
then queen h8 and mate so it's kind of a
nice little mating pattern i think that
somehow my opponent was under the
impression that this didn't work unless
i put upon an h4
or i had a knight on g5 already already
but this is still a mating pattern
and all right so
uh so nice job yeah and again guys like
i'm not gonna see all your variations
right like the
especially when there are lots of lines
going um
but uh so if i miss your variation
like it's just something that can happen
it's not a personal thing
uh but again we're not we're not really
trying to race to the right line right
we're trying to
um we're trying to calculate accurately
and do everything i would say that
i would value like a very accurate line
over a line that spit out fast
so we're not really trying to race each
other it's more about being accurate and
trying to
figure things out here so qui takes a7
queen takes b4 knight g6
um yeah and here it's just kind of the
position falls apart because
i i take the g5 pawn and now there's
just too much so here i mean
even the end of the game which was kind
of funny like even this position it was
largely about the king i make sure my
king is secure
and then i actually just try to weaken
his king and this is something that
people forget like when they're up a
pawn
they often think okay let me just get
the queens off let me just do this
but a lot of the times making your
opponent's king feel the heat making it
so that their king feels bad
is actually a good way is good technique
because you make it so that
they have to defend against attacks and
that's kind of what happened right just
to show you what happened quincy won
i'm gonna go quickly because i really
want time for that last example it's a
really cool position
uh queen b7 h6
g6 and again i'm just trying to
attack their king now i'm not going to
mate their king most likely
but it's at least a good distraction so
i play b4 again i'm just trying to push
this pawn
my queen threatens to come to f6 so the
knight has to go to a passive square
and now i just use my v pawn right
and this is again kind of the trick
right i'm not necessarily going to mate
like knight g5 maybe i can eventually
mate uh if i can get that move in
but for the moment i'm not really trying
to mate i'm actually just trying to
distract so the knight has to be on h7
in order to guard everything and then
this b-pawn just can't be defended
against
so basically you play on both sides of
the board you let them know that the
king side's weak and then you just use
your extra b-pawn
so rook c4
b6 and again here there's not much to do
he plays f5
and then i break through over here so
queen a7 so once again
using the fact that the king is weak
yeah
to finish off the game and then here and
he resigned because
yeah here there's rook ca check is an
unstoppable threat
uh because this queen will give mate if
they take with the queen
so again i mean just an example though
of how how significant the kings were to
the result of the game
uh ah sam showed this game that's
interesting
um yeah
sam actually uh was a student of mine
like a long long time ago uh
so it's funny like uh you know we
sometimes use each other's games and
lectures and stuff like that
but uh but that's funny that he used
this game
but yeah the main point is just the the
king was such an important piece because
because black's king was weak black
structurally black was fine but because
the king was weak
it proved to be just a indefensible
position and improving my own king made
it so that
he was under pressure to do to lash out
because
just the act of improving my king made
his position really annoying
oh it wasn't this game okay he's shown
the same thing
yeah okay so anyways
i have seen him use my games as an
example but he actually used one of my
losses in his book i was really mad at
him about that but
no it's uh it happens
okay so that was that and then you get
to see fish once again
as i open up my last game
for this lecture so this one
yeah this was a really incredible
example
some of you um may have seen it
um
i don't know i mean it became kind of a
famous game at the time but it was a
little more obscure and it's again
played by the same player uh dennis uh
he's matulin against pablo elianov
this was in the european individual
championships 2015 and this was i think
the
on the way to uh his maturing becoming
like a 2700 plus player
but i guess you missed it i mentioned at
the beginning of the lecture that he's a
player who
uh was very just very interesting to
watch with his games but you might not
know about him because he's
more obscure he's not a carlson or a
caruana he's not as high rated so
but he's very interesting player to
watch
so he got this position and i remember
looking at this game and i was thinking
okay i mean maybe heading towards a draw
you know not not anything too crazy the
black king's a little open
but the white king's kind of weird the
pawn on d3 is pretty strong maybe black
could even try something but i thought
that this game was probably headache to
a draw
and the way that this game ended was
absolutely
outrageous
like again one of the most incredible uh
endings to a game thank you francisco i
appreciate that
so the question here is
what should we play as white so we're
facing this d-pawn coming up the board
um our c pawn looks like a gunner the
key at h6 at the moment looks fairly
safe
so what do we do
yeah quincy one definitely probably will
defend um
i don't know though i mean i would be
slightly worried like sometimes after a
move like queen c1
um i don't know queen b5 is is maybe a
move
it's also possible by the way to take
play here you have to go to d1 and then
for example take this pawn and go here
and i get a rook behind the pawn i mean
probably you can draw this like i would
suspect that this
end game is a draw with best play but
you're still the one who maybe has to
work the main thing that's saving you
here
not saving you but making it easier is
that this king on h6 is kind of out of
the game
so it's very unlikely you're ever going
to be in danger here but these are all
kind of ways to try to draw
um i don't know though quick one it
definitely looks like you can run into
trouble playing this way as well so i
wouldn't say it's super clear
but anyway uh quincy one of course is is
a playable move but
again his matulin was thinking to play
more aggressively
so that's a really cool line
um so if rook c1
d2 rook takes queen
it looks like you you've uh blundered
right because queen
here but the problem is if you take the
rook well first of all i guess you could
take the rook on d1 but there's also
even c7 but yeah actually
this is even just simpler um
so that's not very good but i don't have
to play d2 right for example if i play
the move queen b5 with the idea of d2
check next move
this actually looks kind of nasty so
king g1
d2
um so divina queen h8 for queen of five
eight hope um
you have the right idea and in fact that
is what was played in the game
rather than trying to draw with moves
like queen c1 or rooksy one
what actually plays against black's king
and claims you know what the king on h6
is actually not that safe so queen h8
again
i'm not saying it's better than queen
sioux one or rookie one but it's kind of
a cool idea that
you're really trying to actually prove
that you're the one with the initiative
here despite
really only playing with your queen
because the rook on d1 is so passive
so it's a really cool idea that was
played in the game
so in this position there are
two kind of possible so in the game
queen c2 is played which
looks very tempting you're basically
saying look i'm gonna take your rook i'm
gonna play d2
uh it looks like a very strong move but
believe it or not queen c2
is actually a huge mistake
ah so we have a question hold on a
moment so after
rook c1 queen b5 what happens if we push
the pawn
uh if you push the pawn i'll play this
move with check
king h2 i'm probably going to take this
yeah take here and then rook c6 and you
can make a queen
and get your material back but you're
not going to be better here i'll take
your queen for example and i don't know
queen c5 is a move
uh but you're not really better here i'm
the one with the past pawn so i would
say that this is again a way to try to
draw and maybe you can
but you're only trying to draw there and
you're probably on the worst end of it
so uh queen h8 is an attempt to try to
do a little bit more but it it has
amazing tactical points behind it
because it looks like a mistake after a
move like queen c2 which is what
alliance played
so black actually should play rook takes
c6
and here there are many ways to draw but
just for example after rook here
one kind of funny line goes like this
check you take here
you check and you take the rook but
because black's king is open
there's actually no way to avoid a
perpetual here um so this would
with this would be a draw with best play
for example if you try to move f6 i
could even play h4 check
and all of a sudden the black king has
problems so you'd have to go back and
this
should be a draw with best play but once
again this
at least forces uh black to accept a
perpetual it draws the game immediately
so i think that he definitely didn't
want to play one of these end games or
maybe he's a bit worse
so in the game queen c2 is played
queen f8 check king g5
and again this was one of those
positions which was absolutely
crazy to me and really really cool to
watch it was definitely not something i
anticipated here i thought that black
was maybe better or maybe even winning
um but this was definitely quite a
shocking moment
so queen f6 uh queen fah check king g5
and again i'm looking not just for a
move but for some variations
so what ideas do we have here
i'm seeing exclamation parts throw
exclamation marks thrown out there all
this other stuff but i do not see any
lines or anything that would convince me
that
something is correct
k1 saves the white king but it drops the
rook with check
if you want to play a move like that you
need a follow up
quee takes d1 king king the h2 is not i
mean
that's just uh that's nothing it's just
what the force moves
oh my goodness i'm seeing way too many
exclamation points
f4 is most certainly a move
hey keep in mind guys if you've seen
this game before it's going to be a lot
easier
to find the win obviously however the
key to
knowing that to figuring this out is not
just knowing the move but this is
um like
it's not just about knowing the move but
seeing the ideas behind it is what's
really difficult
so yes if you've seen the game you may
know the move but you got to figure out
the ideas behind it
so f4 is definitely a very tempting move
and this actually shows you kind of the
importance i believe because i'm pretty
sure that black can play this now
and the problem is you can chase this
king all the way up
but actually you're the one who's going
to get mated here because the kick at h2
is nice and secure kwedi 2 checks a
threat
and it's actually a completely safe king
which is really funny
so this would be an example of uh the
way this can go wrong
and i don't really see any improvement
to this if you try to play king ji won
i could even i could if i take the rook
you play here and maybe you're actually
going to mate me
but i don't take the rook i ignore you
and i improve my king and now g2 is
going to be a really big problem
so i'm seeing suggestions of h4 this
move is
definitely worthy of consideration so i
guess the question i would have
now is what happens if i play king g4
with the same idea i want to improve my
king ah there's f3 and takes d6 check
though
yeah that's a problem okay so i'm gonna
have to play king h5 probably
so what are we doing here after king h5
so you can play g4 check but now i think
i could take this
and i'm not exactly sure what your
follow up is now
you could check on on c8 but i can even
play f5 there
so i'm not so sure after k here takes g4
you have it if you get particular
um looks really good
um so once again uh this position y to
move
and again i've seen the line i've seen
the move um
but there's the move by itself is
meaningless you need
an actual variation to show why why it
works because it's an amazing move
but what exactly is the idea
so the move played in the game because i
have to finish this up
it's kg1 so again i saw this in the chat
but once again you need
explanations you need reasons why it
works because you're just hanging a rook
with check otherwise
so black did in fact take on d1 with
check which isn't even the best move the
best try it turns out is this move rook
d5 which is really hard to find
obviously this is computer but the idea
is then you improve your king
if kui takes c6 you can play qui g7
and then you have this really nice move
e4
and again you're you're just trying to
go after the king and if king takes e4
you have rookie one check winning the
queen
uh but notice how you're not gonna play
g4 check
because that would allow kigi for
so instead you play kick of six
and then here e4 is very strong
so the idea is that if the rook moves
you play queen d6 check
you take and you get this kind of weird
end game you have to block at the rook
or else you get mated and then rook f3
is quite strong notice how you do not
play here because of takes on f2
so rook f3 here and again it's not even
clear you can necessarily win this
black's gonna kind of use the b-pawn to
distract you but at the very least
you'll get a position
where you end up taking on f6 someday
and taking the b pawn and you get a
queen ending him up upon
uh the odds of you uh actually
actually winning this are like at least
somewhat
reasonable right but again this would
have been by far the best defense
um this rook d5 move
so so uh
yeah i have to end this unfortunately
but um
but yeah i mean there are lots of crazy
lines the the major the main thing
though is just the idea that
improving your king can be worth like
hanging a rook sometimes
it's kind of a cool thing because this
isn't like the shorts thing where he
puts his king on h6 that's really
awesome by the way
but this is just a subtle king move and
all of a sudden black's king just by the
queen and by the king used to help
against the king gets mated so the way
the game concluded was really cool i'll
show it queen takes d1
king here and you're actually just made
it he took here queen e7 check
they just repeated and then he took so
the idea now is f4 check is
absolutely crushing um and you're just
going to try to give mate so alyanna
finds an amazing defense actually
if you try king h6 for example i'll
check
play g4 check with f4 coming or queen h6
it's going to be mates
if queen e2 immediately you just check
and check and that's going to be made as
well
after king h4 queen h6
so rook f6 is what he tried with the
idea that you sacrificed the rook in
order to pin the g pawn
but here his methulen found a really
accurate continuation to the very end he
checked
played here forcing the h pawn up checks
on e5
and once again the kings are just so
important the only reason why it's not
mating by force immediately is because
the pin the only reason black's in
trouble is this king on h5
and how it can't go anywhere if g8 if g5
you actually just keep forcing the king
up and then you just win
uh which is kind of cool and after king
h4
you check this happened in the game and
then this move f5 is very strong
so the idea is that on g5 you play queen
g6 check so he had to take
and now once again the king's just in a
box in a coffin whatever you want to
call it g3
is coming if the queen moves otherwise
kui takes h6 check
and leading to mate um
so again i mean this was all really
really really complicated
um i probably should have budgeted my
time better so i could show that a
little bit closer
um but definitely a
uh definitely a really really cool game
and one that's worth exploring but
honestly i could spend a whole lecture
just on the sub-variations of this
but the main thing to take away is that
a lot of the times in positions when
you're not sure what to do or you're
trying to attack and it doesn't work
or you're unsure of like who's better in
a position look at the kings
uh because often times the kings dictate
oh who's better and why and also
improving your king or making your
opponent's king worse
even in a subtle way can often make the
difference between having a good
position
and doing you know having
greater problems so anyway guys i hope
you
enjoy the lecture i'm going to do
another one right now uh
showing the games of the week so stay
tuned for that